dude i was in louisville one time i came
out of a show they had a big group in a
limousine they invited me to go to after
party with them right
i was like i'm only coming if my boy can
come in like who's your boy
and i'm like look cedric they had a
brother nearby right wearing this louis
vuitton jacket dude
probably about sixty percent homeless
right and they're like that's your boy
and i didn't even talk to this dude
right i was like yeah that's my boy like
all right he can come
so i [ __ ] walk over him looking right
in the eyes and i was like
what's up man i'm theo he's like and uh
i was like all right dude i told these
people you're my friend you ever been in
a limousine he's like nah
i was like all right come get him with
us just act like you're my friend right
we're going to a party he's like all
right man so we go in the limo right
we're in there hot chicks dudes people
[ __ ]
little cedric kept saying we're friends
that's what he kept saying out loud
right
not the best actor bro what did we get
to this house party
it's a nice cool [ __ ] party bro i'm
downstairs i'm in the kitchen
somebody's making us a drink i'm talking
to somebody
[ __ ] is six minutes later right here if
i get
somebody scream i hear a window break
right
somebody comes running down they said
some dude just stole like four purses
out of the coat room upstairs and
[ __ ] jumped out a window
that would have been me doug and that
was [ __ ] less cedric bro
and that was like but and everybody
there was like crying and pissed
and some girl was like furious because
all her tampons were in there or
something i remember
she got pissed she was a tough girl she
was like one of those uh
one of those people that slide the thing
on the ice she said curlers
she was a curler but i was
in my head i was like this is the best
[ __ ] night ever and
i flew a few weeks after 9 11
and um and after 9 11 the world went a
little bit
crazy you know understandably the rules
changed and there was a lot of
anger and fear and confusion and finger
pointing
and um i'd always consider myself quite
a rational
liberal sort of guy um and i tried to
remain that
way after 9 11 um and even in like
in the pub with mates i'd be the ones
going no you can't say that no that's a
generalization that's that's ridiculous
no
no that's that's unfair you can't tie
over the same brush
no it's still the safest form of
transport it's 16 million to one the
chance of it
you know trying to be rational that's in
a pub
when i'm flying it's more like check him
again can we check him again
he's getting on this but do you mind if
i check him can i just
can i just so
okay once i was flying back from new
york
okay uh 9 25 a saturday night jfk
to london heathrow ba first class
okay now this is my point
it's fear that threatens rational
thought
i think okay i'm there
now the whole week leading up to that
flight i don't know if you remember it
or it's happened more than once i don't
know it was a couple of years ago
on every news channel in america there
was a rolling ticker tape that said
america on red alert we've had intel
there's going to be another 911
in a major city probably new york or la
okay
this weekend do not fly unless you
absolutely had to
right i had to i was filming and um
right so i'm the only one in the first
class lounge
okay and i still try to remain rational
i was thinking no
it's safer now everyone's looking for a
terrorist today
they'll leave it till monday right
and then it happened the thing that
threatened my rational thought i had a
little
a bit of a mini breakdown into the first
class lounge
about 30 minutes before boarding came
this guy i don't know whether he was
north african
or middle eastern or asian but he had
all the gear
all right
beard steer the tacho case
okay and here's your middle class sort
of
liberal i went
i was suddenly engaging staff in sort of
banal conversation going
flight on time they're going yeah what's
the weather like in london like they're
going to go
it's a bit cloudy but there he is right
didn't happen so i'm left there right
and i'm looking over at him
and i'm thinking of all the the running
up to it and the weak
or the news and everything but now
there's a fight between good and evil
between rational and irrational okay
this one goes
oh that's a suicide bomber
oh that is stupid of course it isn't it
is how do you know
that's what they look like
what beard
don't be stupid right then he makes a
phone call and i couldn't understand
what he was saying but he sounded a bit
angry
okay this one goes oh we made a phone
call all right
this one no you just made a phone call
yeah but not in foreign
oh shut up right it's been checked like
the rest of us has been checked
did they check the beard yeah they
checked the beard yeah
and then i'm looking at him must have
been absent-minded with all this going
on in my head
and he catches me looking and he does
this
he goes oh he knows he knows right
this one goes no he knows why you're
looking at him he's had that sort of
prejudice for months now stop looking at
him
little beard yeah right
but this one starts winning the fear
starts beating
all the rational thought in the world he
was going no but it could be
well yeah it could be probably not well
no the stats are up today
yeah but still it won't happen don't say
it won't happen to us
people of 911 said it wouldn't happen to
them yeah but all the tests yeah they
find new ways of
getting through our detection then we
have to go yeah you're right and
suddenly i thought
oh my god this is it this is it and that
wave of nausea and you suddenly realize
oh my god i'm witnessing this this one
goes okay
right let's report him this one goes no
why in case someone thinks we're racist
no [ __ ] that let's let's report him and
be a a wrong
embarrassed live racist just in case
right and i don't know
so i don't and so now i think he is a
suicide bomber and i think i'm going to
get on the plane and die
but i'm not going to do anything about
it and i'm nearly in tears and all this
happens in a few moments
and i look over and he's joined by his
wife who's got all the gear
and um his two little girls okay
and i suddenly go oh of course he's not
a [ __ ] suicide bomber
if you're off to see 72 virgins you
don't take the wife and kids alone
and our minds kind of work the same and
what's funny
i think i've told this story before is
when mtv cribs came out we both did a
bid on it
and it was ridiculous how similar it was
i think we both even said britney spears
i think we both said helicopter
really yeah i don't know what it was and
i remember i was at the cellar
and i did it and he was standing there
you know greg was a cool [ __ ] dude
man yeah
he was a tough dude too he grew up in
new york when new york was like
warriors and he was like i used to fight
all the time
on subways coming home from school and
what i loved about him was he was a real
sweetheart
but he hated bullies and i used to see
when someone was bullying somebody
you'd you'd see the bull like the flame
coming in his eyes
and like he'd become this subway greg
so i always respected that about him
and um but anyway
uh so we i he can i get off stage and
then greg says to me
he goes uh you know oh man he goes i
hate to do this
and i knew he's gonna say i go what i go
which joke
he goes the mtv cribs thing and i'm like
[ __ ]
he goes it's almost verbatim i'm like
god damn it so then we're both standing
there
and we had both just i made like a cd
and he just
did a i don't know i don't know he done
we both done stuff and we needed the
joke at that moment
yeah so we so we made a pact we go all
right here's the deal
we'll just do it on the road deal and i
deal so
neither one of us do it in the city
of course time goes on there's a million
things happening
we both forget yeah so i get my half
hour on comedy central and so does he
and we both do the bit
shut the [ __ ] up
so then the funny thing was was mine
came out first
oh and then his came out and he called
me up and we were laughing our asses off
because it was the early days of the
internet and they were just going in on
greg
you thieving piece of [ __ ] you took it
from that
that that uh that brian burr guy that
nobody knew me i was so early in my
career you took it from that
red-headed [ __ ] guy
[Music]
i took chris rock and my manager out on
it one night chris didn't want to go
and he came anyway and we went out to
the statue of liberty
and uh there was this thing floating in
the water chris saw it he said what is
that and it was this big thing and it
was dark
it was night it was like one in the
morning so it looked like
uh like a raft from a ship you know like
a big round raft that's what it looked
like to me
yeah and i yelled over hey is anyone in
that boat
and didn't have any lights or anything
and then we noticed that it was coming
towards us
like kind of with some speech and chris
goes get the
[ __ ] away from that thing like it was
creepy so i backed away from it yeah and
i put a light on it and it was
it was like it looked like a giant
manhole cover sticking out of the
river this was the weirdest night of
[ __ ] ever
and it's right by this nautical mystery
yeah right by the statue of liberty it's
like
i don't know 20 feet across and it's
moving
it's propelling through water are you
sure it was moving or it didn't just
it was clear i was leaving awake wow
what the [ __ ]
so submarine i call up well if the real
uh
channel 16 i go is anyone monitoring
this channel or something because the
staten island ferry was very close to
there and i thought this it could easily
sink that any fairy i would have sunk if
i had hit it yeah
really had you backed away from it by
the time you called in yeah
and so i called in and then this woman
came on this is a new york harbor coast
guard
call uh give me your your home number i
mean your phone number if you have a
phone so i give her my number this guy
calls
and he says what are you seeing and i
describe it and i he goes describe it as
well as you can and my manager i said
what does that look like he goes i'm
really sorry but it looks like a summary
it looks like the top of us like like
the hatch
of a submarine so i go i don't want to
cause a problem but it looks like the
hatch of a submarine
and it's headed towards lower manhattan
that's actually
that's what i'm seeing and i'm sure it's
not that but
my main concern is it's not lit and it
could cream anything that hits it's
going down
and the guy goes all right well i'll
call a boat and
send him to you so he hangs up and like
20 minutes later there's nobody there
and i call him back and we have the
light on it and i have this weird
feeling like is it going to
shoot at us
[ __ ] starts coming at you yes chris
rock fell asleep
like he's just like you guys are idiots
and he went to sleep
that's why people know you know where
life no i don't usually
kids do observe water safety what are
you [ __ ] quentin
again take a bat to the radio submarine
in the water our submarine
so anyway we call i call back and
they're not sending anybody
and i said at one point i got crazy and
i was like i said what are you what do
you do if somebody's
you are the coast guard and i am saying
to you now there's a
there's a submarine attacking lower
manhattan this is like saying it just
like jimmy's story with the bus only on
the water
yes when you're very similar to the
stolen bus like how would why
wouldn't if that did happen someone
would see it and call in
and they're like we're trying to get
park police over here i'm like send a
[ __ ] helicopter uh we know about it
mr ck
how do you know my name how do you know
my name right
they knew exactly what this thing was oh
wow and he kind of asked me to hover we
kept hovering around it and stuff and
then finally this big police boat comes
and shines like a massive light on it
and then he calls
hails me on the radio uh hey captain are
you the one who uh
captain who reported this and i go yeah
and he goes uh
it's a mooring ball it's been there
since 1965
and i go i'm really sorry i'm really
sorry i wasted your time
you didn't know you've never seen a
bunch of moorings dancing
i know that was delicious
that's all right you thought it was sean
connery defecting
ball oh big iron [ __ ] uh
it's on a chain yeah i guess people tie
up to it and i'm like
what if you don't see it and everybody
the guy in the
well most people navigating those waters
know what the [ __ ] they're doing right
that's why it's probably marked on a
chart that there's a mooring problem
when you were off to the side getting
away from because you initially said it
was coming towards you
yeah leading away it looks like it was
going towards me because it's on a chain
to the bottom
yeah so when the current takes it looks
like it's moving it's not just drifting
it must have like just the river moving
the car
i have no business being on the water
because oh yeah
it looks like it's moving in one
direction to me because i'm [ __ ]
moving so it's making like a circle
and i keep moving around it and i'm
going holy [ __ ]
where the [ __ ] are we shorts geez we're
really moving far away there's a giant
thing coming out of the water
that's the statue of liberty you idiot
it's like a floating sea from another
planet that's manhattan
new york city it's atlantis
were you were you like running through a
fantasy in your head of louis c.k
[ __ ] a terrorist terrorist sported by
comics
instead the headline reads and quotes
comic arrested for pranking police
department
local local comics